and finally new rule america's top
health officials have to find the
courage
to do what the health officials in
huntington new york did
they told the entire town of 200 000 to
go on a diet because as the head of the
program put it
with covet 19 you're twice as likely to
have a poor
outcome if you're obese
actually it's worse than that public
health england
found that people with a body mass index
of 35 to
40 have a 40 percent greater risk of
dying
from covet and over 40 it's a 90 percent
greater risk
even being mildly obese makes it five
times more likely that catching the
virus will land you in the icu
and now people are gaining even more
weight they call it the quarantine 15.
geez i remember when plagues had a
slimming effect on people
i don't think it's a coincidence that
the countries with the lowest
rates of obesity have had the fewest
covet deaths
maybe china isn't hiding all their covet
deaths
maybe their secret is that their obesity
rate is six percent
and ours is 42. and pointing all this
out doesn't make
me a dick in fact the shame
is on everyone in media and government
who is too cowardly to emphasize
how important an issue this is
because the virus made it an issue
obesity was already killing us slowly
but you mix it with covet
and it kills you fast you can scream all
you want at me for saying that but it
won't change the scientific truth of it
look no one deserves to die because of
their weight
and we should spare no expense
protecting vulnerable people no matter
why they're vulnerable but make no
mistake
america fighting kovid is like a boxer
who went into the ring out of shape and
is taking a beating for it
every day we hear the same warnings
about fighting the virus
wear a mask wash your hands have sex
through a glory hole
but the people in charge of health
during a health crisis
dr fauci dr burks
surgeon general adams head of the cdc
dr redfield national institutes of
health director
dr francis collins they never really
mentioned the one major thing
most people could do to ensure a better
outcome should they get it
to me it's such a scandal these doctors
won't look straight in the camera and
say
the number one thing you can do to
improve your chances
is to be in better general health and
the number one route to that
is an improved diet to be a doctor right
now
and not discuss diet it's like being a
clown who won't do balloon animals
why not an all-out campaign to educate
the public
on the dangers of a diet of sugary
chemical-laden crap
krispy kreme honored
our front-line doctors and nurses in
april by giving them 18 million
donuts which is like honoring firemen
with napalm
and why not a campaign to make it a
priority to get decent food
into poor neighborhoods why not for
every psa about a mask
a psa with a recipe for a healthy meal
i think so many lives could have been
saved if at the very beginning of this
crisis
the medical establishment had made a
more concerted effort
to tell americans while you're in
lockdown
getting free money for not working you
need to do something
too even the poorest person could switch
out
soda at meals for water it'll save you
money too
the national campaign to get in shape
would have dramatically
improved our chances against this
disease and made us feel better about
ourselves to boot
but it was never even mentioned even in
a country that
loves challenges the ice bucket
challenge planking
all the this will make you puke
challenges
condoms up your nose the mannequin
challenge
quite a challenge that one why couldn't
they have gotten behind
a real challenge like oh i don't know
getting healthy so the virus doesn't
kill you
challenge but as michelle
obama found out just trying to give
sound nutritional advice gets you
vilified in america
you're a health nut yeah that's what
they say about people who just eat right
they're
nuts into weird hippie [ __ ] like
vegetables
no no we need to stop glamorizing
gluttony
diabetes isn't just a theory and with
this virus
now enablers and glorifiers
you're playing with people's lives if
you're always on about how this is a
life and death issue and it is
we can't have body positivity be a third
rail anymore political correctness can
kill i've seen it before
this issue is too fundamental to who
lives
and who dies and to how successful
america
is going to be in getting out of this
crisis